Hello everyone and welcome to
today's webinar Cervical Cancer Screening
in the Age of Notification My
name is María Antonieta Chávez
Marketing Manager You're welcome and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational webinar is
hosted by  the light and brought to you
by the
Apps molecular division science affairs team before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that l20 is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many questions
as you wish at any time during
the presentation to do so simply
write your  question in the Ask yourself a
question box and click the Send button
to send we will answer as many
questions as we have time at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click the Support tab at the
top right of  the
presentation window or let us know about your
problem by clicking on the box to
this questio  n located on the far
left of the screen,
I would now like to introduce our
presenter today, Dr. Bonilla is
a surgeon specializing in
gynecology and obstetrics with
subspecialization in pathology of
the lower genital tract and colposcopy
for the diagnosis and treatment
of patients with
gynecological diseases and  Obsthetics with emphasis
on prevention, diagnosis and management of
pre-neoplastic diseases of
the cervix, vagina and vulva For more
information on his biography, visit the
biographic tab at the
top of the window.
Today and so
important for all our women,
not only
Latin American but all women
in the world since cervical cancer
continues to occupy the second cause of
cancer mortality in women and
in young women of childbearing age
where we cannot take
actions  aggressive in her ma  nejo
Today we are in the molecular era
and the molecular era is related to
the identification of the main
risk factor for this cervical cancer disease
before starting
this notice where we are
accepting the invitation of Laboratories
to issue this is important  talk and your support for this
very important program as I was saying for
both our women and
our schools
the human papillomavirus because the
most interesting thing is to remember the history
and the 14 genotypes related to
cervical cancer have been
fully identified almost 20 years ago
years is I wanted to bring to begin My
talk
this bibliography from 2003 where the New
England Journal publishes the findings
of Dr. Muñoz from Dr. Southhouse
where they find a
large participation of the
human papillomavirus in cancer patients What does this mean they
took cancerous tumors  of these
women and found in the tumors that
in 54% of them there was the presence
of HPV 16
in 11% HPV 18 in 4% of hpv-45
Likewise, a subgroup was made in these
women with cancer where the
presence of HPV was evidenced is 31 33
52 58 and  other number of viruses other
groups of viruses genotypes that had
a lower prevalence but that as a
whole completed the 14 genotypes
related to cervical cancer
in this same publication we can
definitely see that
worldwide the genotypes involved
in cervical cancer are  HPV 16 58%
Here the prevalence changes because
I am talking about a worldwide data of
15% for 18 and 5.9 for 45. So
research is focused
on detecting these HPVs and after their
discovery and their participation in
cancer, research is focused  in
preventing
infection by this type of virus through vaccination,
then we can say that
cervical cancer is one of the few
cancers where a
viral participation as the
main risk of the disease
let's look at this by age groups How
these three viruses behave so
frequent and prevalent in the
disease when we analyze
patients under 34 years of age worldwide, we
find that HPV 16 continues to be
prevalent over 18  and 45 when the
woman is a little older
the prevalence of HPV 16 decreases and
the prevalence of hpv-45 increases,
however it is much more prevalent 60%
versus 16 or 7 percent HPV 16 and
in patients older than 50 years it
decreases  the prevalence of HPV 45
while HPV 16 and 18 remain important
what do I mean by this that
the age group does not matter we are not interested in the age
of the patients in cervical
cancer at different ages
hpv-16 18 and 45 are present and
this makes these viruses
a risk for
healthy women to get cervical cancer
How is the prevalence of the disease
in m  healthy women This is an
extremely important fact women without
cancer we find that the three viruses
that we have mentioned genotype 16 18 and 45
are the most prevalent and not 50 60
percent as it was in cancer but
we can say that one in four
healthy women  can have HPV 16
Also look at the three groups,
let's say the high median and low
prevalence are
constantly found. Compared with cancer patients,
what does this mean or what
is the best message we have HPV in
healthy women does not mean then
that when  When we are delivering
the result of a positive HPV test,
we must classify the patient as
having a precancerous disease or with
a cancer disease. She
is simply infected with the virus that is the main
risk factor for the disease and from
then on we have a series of
steps left.  that are going to help us to rule
out the presence or not of the
disease in it, this infection is simply
infected  ion for human papillomavirus
is directly related to
age. You see that patients
under 30 years of age have a high
prevalence of human papillomavirus
, hence many of the
clinical practice guidelines indicate that HPV tests should not be
performed for
under 30 years why because we will
find a large number of women who are
positive for the infection but
negative for the disease, that is, they
have the virus but do not have cancer or
precancerous lesions,
this high prevalence is maintained
preferably in those under 25
years of age, so  A question arises, what do we do
with women Between 25 and 30 years old
for their screening and at that moment
we found two routes,
one route could be, since the
prevalence of the virus is so high,
we could only do
cytology
and wait for the patient to reach 30
years to start HPV testing
but we could also say that at
age 25 the prevalence is so
We could start HPV testing after the age of 25.
So you will
find management guidelines that say
that we start HPV testing at age 25
and other guides that say that we
should start at age 30, both
behaviors are accepted and I think that
the  decision is an economic decision if
I am a country that has
sufficient income to provide my population
with HPV tests from 25 years of age, then
I am authorized to do so because the
literature and clinical
experience confirm it, but if I do not have the
financial resources I can  delay to start
screening with HPV tests at 30
years of age
and A question arises will be that all these
young women who have
human papillomavirus are going to give us cancer
what will happen to women with
human papillomavirus
I wanted to bring you  an example based
on data from globocan 2019 I took some
high-income countries and take
Latin American countries or low- and medium-income
countries
and  I took an average of the incidence
of cervical cancer the average
gives us 29 per hundred thousand inhabitants of all
these countries is an example this
exercise shows us the following if I
take an age group over 25 years my
incidence of cancer in all  countries
will be much higher than when I
compare it with an age group under
25 Look what happens we are
concluding then that young patients
have a high prevalence of
HPV but the incidence of cancer in
them is extremely low
let's compare it with mortality and
The same thing happens to us. We take an average in
these countries of mortality
from cervical cancer and it gives us 12 per
100,000 inhabitants in patients between 25 and
69 years of age.
But if I take the age group
below 25 years, I see that I do not
find mortality  by cancer
these few figures these
small data 0.05
0.14 per 100,000 inhabitants for an
average of 0.06 worries colleagues
In anecdotal data So c  When one
is trying to design a
cervical cancer prevention program and
one invites colleagues to start
screening over 25 years of
age, there is anecdotal data from
colleagues who have had in their
private practice or in their institutional practice
the occasional case of cancer in children
under 25 years of age, the important thing here is to see
how all countries behave the same
in that they are very sporadic cases
and when a program is designed that
includes the entire country and the entire
population for the prevention of
neck cancer  uterine So looking at this
statistic one wants to start
screening over 25 years of
age where
the presence of the disease truly occupies an important place.
What happens then with that HPV if all the
young women had HPV the prevalence was
very high but they do not cause cancer  do not cause
cancer because the majority of these women,
as shown by the studies that are
here on this slide by these
authors, give us  have shown that most
of these women achieve viral clearance
between 6 and 12 months after
acquiring the infection in blue lines,
studies for six months or 93%
of women did not have the virus at
six months and in green lines  which is the
majority of the bibliography, studies that
indicate that between 37 and 77% of
patients after 12 months do not have
the human papillomavirus infection,
there is a study here in our
country in Cali in 2003 that shows
that 92% of the women in a
six to five-year follow-up did not
have human papillomavirus
so what happens is that
young women clear up the virus
over time and do not
develop the disease
then a question arises, we know that
Human papillomavirus is the
main risk factor. We know
that most women
clear up the infection and that
very few will persist with the
infection and that persistence  The disease is going to
lead to cancer,
so the strategy changes, it is no longer a
matter of identifying those women
whose cytological results are
abnormal, but trying to identify
those women who are at risk of
suffering the
disease based on risk. I bring you this
publication by doctor polla  where you
compare What is the risk that a
woman has if her Pap smear is negative
over time of developing the
disease
And you see that women with
negative smears over
time increase the risk of having the
disease
starting with a Pap smear  negative
thing very opposite to what happens with
those women who do not have
human papillomavirus women with
negative HPV tests do not have the risk of
developing the disease over
the years and three years later
the risk slightly increases if there was the
viral persistence already so here there are
minimal viral loads that were not
detected or negative patients  s that
finally become contaminated and can
cause the disease, but I had a
space of three years to assure those
negative women that they will not
develop the disease. And this is
not provided by cytology from that point
of view as a screening strategy, it
is safer to start  with
human papillomavirus tests than with
cytology or as some countries do
that we will see later with a
cocktail of cytology plus HPV test
This is one of the main advantages
of including HPV tests as is
being done in many countries  in the world
as screening or as the main BP test
What is the problem, then,
starting screening with BPA tests
is it possible to have a
higher sensitivity than cytology? We are talking
about 60 to 70% in cytology
versus 90 to  100% of the
HPV tests but let's remember that the
human papilloma virus test is
identifying those
infected women but not us  á
identifying the women whose
infection caused the
precancerous lesion or cancer. In other words, it is not
identifying the sick women,
which is why
we must add a
highly specific test to this highly sensitive test to know
Within this group that it can be according to
the  clinical studies between 10 and 16%
of the population is HPV positive
Which of these patients 10 to 16% will
be sick So we have many
options for tests that have greater
specificity
Which of these infected
Yes they are sick and deserve to go to
complementary studies of  colposcopy
to God Two extremely important issues arise here
What happens with colposcopy in high
-income countries colposcopy
generates a very high extra cost if
we use it in infected patients who are not
sick, that is, those HPV-
positive patients and that any of these
triage tests  is negative
and in low-income countries The
problem is that access  he colposcopy
is limited So I cannot saturate my
colposcopy services with
non-ill HPV positive patients I need to
purge this population to give the
human resource to those who
really need it
and These are the triage tests that
will allow me to do this let's talk a
little about  they the overexpression of 6 is
7 or the immunohistochemistry either done
in cytology or done in tissue
are very specific tests in fact the
same cytology has high specificity
So I could use a
high sensitivity test plus high
specificity tests to decide  Which of the
patients is positive here and positive here
goes to colposcopy But this would generate an
even greater cost overrun for me to use two
molecular tests to get to
colposcopy. It
is for this reason that most
management guidelines
exclude high-specificity tests
to complement the
tests  of HPV
and leave only two alternatives
the cytology that has  With greater
specificity than HPV tests,
then any patient who has a
positive pH test will have a
cytology done. And if the cytology is abnormal, we
send it to colposcopy.
at higher risk that
patient should go directly to
colposcopy is one of the most
important points currently in
cervical cancer screening
genotyping in which viruses will
I support as triage to decide which
patient should live immediately to
colposcopy and which patient can I
delay or defer colposcopy at a
later time
and why it is so important because the
quality of cytology is very diverse
in most countries and quality
or quality control in cytology is
bad in most of our
underdeveloped countries exists  a very bad
quality control in cytology we
cannot guarantee it So it is better to
follow the route of the ge  Notification
to say colposcopy Let's look at an
example then here What will be the
three-year risk
of patients who have HPV positive
Let's just think about the virus
The baseline risk of a woman who
has HPV positive is 11% of
developing a mic2 in  the next
three years and 5% of developing a
mic3 in the next three years
what would be your three-year risk increases if
the virus persists the risk increases
for both nick 2 and nick 3 very
different towards the virus the
risk disappears but  we are going to talk
with the genotyping that
we currently have,
look at the risk, we are going to
base ourselves here on the risk of Nick 3, which
is perhaps the most interesting, the risk
is 6.7% at three years if you have a virus
not 16:18 if you have the  virus 16 this
risk is more than doubled to
16%.  So we are not only interested in
finding out what virus the
patient has if she is positive or negative, but also
what genotype she has in order to establish
the risk of that woman.
In other words, a woman who
has a positive HPV 16
has a 20% risk of having  the
disease at the same time that his
test came out positive, but that
risk can increase by up to 50
percent if the virus persists for three
years, so here we are already beginning to see
something much better than cytology, it
is no longer normal, it is the  risk to
identify these patients
early and guarantee
timely treatment
this publication by doctor polla
confirms what we are seeing here is
something very interesting and that is that in this
publication two different tests are compared
and they all tell us the same thing if a
patient has  HPV 16 positive or 16 18
positive your risk of developing mick 3
is greater both at time zero and at
three years
than  e if you have HPV not 16/18 or if you have
HPVs other than those already
mentioned both in the basal stage
consistency at three years In fact in
this publication the
subgroups of HPV are mentioned and as a subgroup the
second their group 31 33  51 54 these
groups are more at risk than the others
than group B So look at
how genotyping is
helping us to say which
patient is a priority care in which
patient I can defer care for
colposcopy not only in the case of Nick 3
but also in the case of Nick 2,
obviously when one has a
cut-off point of Nick 2 or more,
the casuistry is greater. It is not true, 25%
here the risk rises to 40% here
in three years, but HPV
16 and 1618 will always predominate over  other viral types in
any of the tests that are
done to patients this is a
reality
let's look A very interesting example
Why Because age does not change what we
are saying if I analyze
less patients  In women over 30 years of age, the persistence of
HPV 16,
31 and 33, as you see here, that is, group 1,
group 2,
increases the risk of the disease
over time and in patients over
30 years of age, the prevalence changes. Remember
that we said that young women have a
higher prevalence but the behavior
of viral persistence
increases the risk and these patients
over 30 years of age with HPV 16 with
hpv-31-33 if this virus persists over
time their risk of developing Nick 3
increases ostensibly
helps to see more or less what  What are we
talking about? How is the viral behavior
in the cytological findings and in the
histological findings of the patient?
ascus 13,000 with
low-grade messes 6,000 with high-grade laws
by cytology and there are 14,000 patients with
high-grade leaders and 8,000  patients
with low-grade lesions in
histology And what do they find that the
prevalence of HPV 16 changes according
to the cytological result if I have a
patient with ascus the prevalence of HPV
and 16 is higher than that of the other
viral groups but this prevalence  It
increases when the cytological data is
higher and the high-grade lesions in the
prevalence are almost 50 percent. It is very
important that we make a parenthesis. Here
I am talking about the prevalence of the virus
in pre-neoplastic lesions, not in cancer,
and the same happens with HPV.  18 with
hpv-33 58 that increase
as the cytological lesion worsens
and we can confirm this
in histology and when we
have the biopsy the behavior or
the prevalence of HPV and 16 in 1 is less
than if we have  a carcinoma in Sito and
that HPV 18 that was hidden within the
group begins to increase its prevalence
when the histological lesion worsens and
Look how beautiful it shows us and  This
graph as HPV 16 18 and 45
begin to occupy the first places
when carcinoma is found in the biopsy
Compared with what we saw in
the cytological findings and a second
place begins to be formed by another type
of virus such as 33 52 35 So this
is  very interesting Because if I have
HPV 16 18 45 I should think that the
patient may have a higher
grade lesion than if I have another type of virus and
low grade lesions
this need to know what type of
virus a patient has to know which one
it is the best management makes the
american association of
cervical pathology and colposcopy the assp in 2019 Launch
the new management guide This is
a very interesting management guide for
two reasons first because it is based
on genotyping
and second because it is based on the
history of the patients and It is
logical to understand that it is one thing to have
a patient with HPV and 16 positive and
quite another to have a patient
with HPV and 16 positive but  who has
a history of
having been HPV 16 positive for four or three years.
So this guide establishes
something very interesting, which is the level of
and what is intended to teach
doctors with the management of this guide is
that that group of  Women who have a
risk greater than or equal to four
percent of developing the
disease in the next five years
should go immediately for colposcopy
and those patients who have a risk of
less than 4%.  If we get to have the
disease in the next five years
we can have a not so aggressive management
and we can delay it That is the best
message above 4% go to
colposcopy below 4
% can receive surveillance And these
two large groups So  They are
subdivided
and we can say that the woman whose
risk is 0.15%.  I can see it in
five years, all HPV-negative patients will enter here,
those patients who have a risk
between 0, 15 and 0.54, I can see them in three
years, patients with HPV negative will enter here,
but with a history of
abnormal Pap smears or
with minor changes  an ascus an HPV but
HPV negative
or definitely those patients with
an hpv-45 that could be sewn up in a year
But because it has a 3.9% risk but
you can decide with that 3.9 to go up
to colposcopy then according to the
risk is the management of the patient
definitely
Those patients who have risks
greater than 4% should immediately go
to a colposcopy and something very interesting about
the guide is that it teaches us that
patients like those who have HPV
16 positive should think about giving them
immediate treatment just because they have
HPV and 16 positive with  an
abnormal cytology do not defer them do not prolong his
treatment and apply the schemes that
are known as  or per And treat
let's see it in this risk table This 5%
has been modified to 4% in the new
guide And that has allowed
lesions such as ascus
or the hpv-45 virus to come up to colposcopy so
I can see patients with negative cytology
in 5 years patients with
negative HPV ascus I can see them in three years
patients who have positive HPV with
minor changes I have no risk and
I can see them in a year but from there
all the other cytological findings and
all the other findings in  the
HPV test forces me to take the patients
to a colposcopy there are some exceptions to the
rule Obviously if a patient has
negative HPV But her cytology
suggests a
high risk of cancer
justifies seeing her in a colposcopy and the
risk is not given to me by the virus test
but the cytological abnormality
Likewise here the cytology is negative
but it has hpv-18 or here where the
cytology is negative and it only has
HPV 16 and in that so interesting the fact
alone  or having a positive HPV 16 or 18
would force us, due to the risk, to take the
patient directly to colposcopy
in the case of major, high-grade lesions,
we are no longer interested in the
molecular diagnosis of HPV, the mere fact of having
a cytology that indicates carcinoma
forces us to  take the patient to
colposcopy But what I was telling you,
having a positive HPV 16 with
high-grade cytology, the risk is 60 to almost
80 percent and these patients should go
to colposcopy with
an immediate treatment mentality. So I summarize
this table for you  risk is given by
genotyping the risk is given
by cytological normality and the risk
is what the behavior of What to do
with the patient in the molecular era gives me
then the question arises which test are
we going to use to establish that
risk for that this  publication
helps us terribly why Because
doctor chicken
brings together
193 commercial tests 127 variables of
these tests now And so in this
publication tells us come on, we have almost
300 tests available and this is in
which of those 300 tests should we choose
in our countries to do
genotyping and the first thing
we have to know is if these tests
have adequate quality control
then this new one comes  publication
of 2020 and in this publication it distressingly tells us
the percentage of tests
has grown significantly year after year
but unfortunately not
all the tests can be used
since more than 90% of them do not
meet the recommended quality standards
almost 80%  of them do not
have studies of analytical or
clinical validity and almost 60% of them do not have
studies with
recognized peer-reviewed publications So
not all the tests help us to
implement
the screening with HPV tests in our countries
What would they be Then  the requirements
that these tests must meet
in order to be used A l  The new tests
must first have a sensitivity
close to 90% Compared to capture of
hybrids Remember that capture of
hybrids is a test that
is practically in disuse because it does not give us
immediate notification but it is the basis
we start from there because it is the one that has been used for the
longest  of use and the one with the most clinical studies,
so if I have a
test with 90% sensitivity
for glass capture, I can use it.
But it must also have 98%
specificity in 800 samples with
low-grade lesions or  least and most
importantly at least 500 samples must
show an interlaboratory correlation
greater than 87%.  This 90% of the
sensitivity, 98 of the specificity and 87
of the correlation make a test that can
be admitted or not in the clinic, not in an
analytical way but in a clinic for its
use in prevention programs.
Let's take an example of one of the
new tests which can  Let's take the
limit for example at this time
so the sensitivity for
video capture nick 3 is 97%.  That
means that at the limit it should have a minimum of
90% of 97, that is,
95%.  and what you have is 100%.  and it should
have a minimum of 98% of 90, that is, 88%
specificity and it has 91. So look
at how the new tests not
only
fully meet the requirements
to be admitted but also
far exceed those of the mother test with
which  We are comparing ourselves and they know
with Real Time audio that happens with
all the tests that we are
currently using but not all of the
300 tests that I initially showed you
have those clinical studies something very
important a new test is to compare
their correlation What is their agreement
in the detection of the different viruses
with other already existing tests and look at
the layer is 09 there is a 90 Well
an excellent layer 90% of concordance
when comparing a test like a
limit with covas with Real Time with
array lines that are tests  that have
been in use for a long time,
especially for the diagnosis of high-risk HPV such
as 16 or 18. This is
what I invite you to when  When you sit
at the discussion table, it is not about
seeing which test identifies me
more, more cell group, more HPV groups,
remember that when you are in
the committees to approve tests,
non-medical people say it is not, they are
offering a test that identifies me
20 or 30 types of virus and
the one that identifies 14 is worth the same to me, these
are not clinical concepts, they are not
medical concepts to make a decision, or
that test diagnoses me with a
minimal viral load and the other one I need a
higher viral load.  see
later are not criteria for that
I want to
put
a topic of much discussion because
up to here we have talked
about HPV tests as screening
is an indication of the tests which
patient is at risk and what should I
do with that patient but the tests
HPV tests can also be used as
triage as a second test and I want to
talk about that right now because we are
in the era of genotyping and the
best example that  What I can bring you is the
ties What happens with the assos What
happens with the ascus is that there are a lot of
disgusts. It is estimated that more or less 5%
of all Pap smears taken in a
country are stars. That means that
between the  50 and 60% of the
abnormal cytologies are asci but when one goes to
review these ascuses, disease is found
in very few patients, maximum 12%
when the study als reviewed their ascuses
found that 31% of these ascuses were
negative than 55%  they could not be
defined so let us add here
86% who were patients who did not have a
lesion only 14% of them had
an intraepithelial lesion and yet
all these patients demanded
colposcopy services demanded a
biopsy and generated anguish in many
of the patients who had to go  to
these exams So what do we do with a
lot of ascus little disease
for that we refer to our
management guide to the guide of the
American Association of Colposcopy that tells us if
the risk is greater than 4% that patient
should go to colposcopy and I bring
back the slide to simply tell you
that the ascus is part of
4%.  So according to the new 2019 guide,
ASUS exceeds 4% and 4 to 24% of
patients at risk for Nick 3 should go for
colposcopy.
In view of how we can
solve
it, we can solve it when
we realize that only half of
the hooves are HPV positive that
only 4 to 12% have
high-grade lesions
that the five-year risk is very low
Two points to 6%  and that very few
patients have cervical
cancer So we can see how
70% of ascus cancer We go until
we find between 0.5 and 0.2% of
patients from this point of view
genotyping gives us a hand
so here what we go  What to talk about is the
use of HPV tests as
triage and not choosing all the
positive pH ascus and sending them to colposcopy or
saying that we can control all the negative HPV ascus
in three years in
this  moment we have to answer
a question which HPV the patient has
and then the guide lowers the risk
from 5% to 4%.  and we found that
those patients with ascus who have
HPV 59 56 66 39 or 51 their risk of
developing a mic3 in the next
three years is so low that I can delay
the colposcopy I stop filling my
colposcopy services with these ascus
and give them the opportunity  to the patients
who are most at risk Which are the
patients with hpv-45 Remember that the
previous guideline said this was 5%, so
HPV 45 was far from colposcopy
Now I can raise it to 4% and take
colposcopy to hpv-45 and hpv  -52 and obviously
those patients with a pH of 16 or 18 give me
enough risk for them to
be immediately seen by
colposcopy.
This is so simple that you see here. It has an
immensely large economic repercussion and opportunity repercussion
since these 60% of acts no longer
He sent everything to colposcopy, but
I do a triage, who does the
triage, the genotyping and I can
say where I place the human
and financial resources and where I can wait for
Invest this resource and wait for a while
to give colposcopy to God. This
concept is still not in the
clinical practice guidelines, but it is the
immediate future that awaits us with
genotyping due to the problems
that I have exposed regarding costs or
human resources in colposcopy.  and biopsy
in different countries
finally let's talk a little bit about
analytical sensitivity
and this is an issue that seems
extremely important to me because it lends itself
to confusion, especially among
non-experts on the subject let me give you an
example I can have here I have three
types of tests  I can have
HPV tests that identify me as
high-risk HPV. In this case, the example that
I bring you is HPV 16-18 with very few
copies of HPV. So I have 240
copies of HPV 16, the test is at the limit and
it will  give positive But cobas would
need 600 copies to give me
positive in this case I would have a
positive HPV test for 16 and a
negative test having  with the patient HPV
16 positive
This makes the test at the
beginning better than the covas test or the
clarity bank test If you want, I'll put them
differently I only need 300 tests
300 copies of HPV 33 instead with fungus
clarity I need 1600 and with allinity
This makes it a better test covas
than baseline This is a misconception
this analytical sensitivity
is the test designed to detect
positivity above 2000 copies and
this test is designed for 16 18
above 600 copies I don't care about the
number of  copies analytical sensitivity
I am interested in the presence of
precancer disease or cancer clinical sensitivity
but this misconception
confuses or confuses the
medical staff and the clinical laboratory In which
test is better allow me Here I leave
the doubt to clarify the concept with the following
slides
This  It is a very interesting study. Look,
I am going to talk about a single
genotype on the 16th, but at a concentration
different trations So look how it is the
increased concentration of HPV that
establishes my risk over time I
do not need to identify a copy or two
copies I need to know that the
concentration of virus is
large enough to establish
a mic3 or cancer and the fact that  The fact that
there are viruses like the 16 virus that is
characterized by replicating and
generating a higher
viral load over time is what increases my
risk and that happens with the HPV 16 virus
and it also happens with 18 31 33 and
all viruses on  The risk increases
1.8 or two times
if the concentration increases or let's call it
in quotes and in quotes we have to
talk about the viral load, so the
more number of copies you have
persistently, the more risk you have of
developing the disease, it's called
clinical sensitivity and it has nothing to
do with it.  with analytical sensitivity
then
said these words that we
can conclude we can conclude that
the generation 16  18 and other
viral groups have allowed us to improve the
opportunity for colposcopy in screening
which one I am going to send immediately And in
which one I am going to dilate but if I do an
extended genotyping you can also
start using HPV tests
as triage to improve the opportunity
and  reduce spending on
cervical cancer prevention programs
likewise. Let's never forget that the
clinical sensitivity of
genotyping confirms that it is
important in secondary prevention of
the disease. Cytology now takes
second place with cytology with a
much lower sensitivity than the
HPV tests and never forget that not all
HPV tests offered on the
market can be included in our
prevention programs until
the
corresponding clinical validation clinical studies are completed, it is not
only analytical sensitivity studies,
many, many, many thanks
for having me  heard
thank you very much doctor  Bonilla for your
informative presentation now we are going
to start the live question and
answer part if you have any
questions please at this time for
them just click on the box
until question or ask located on the
far left of the screen we will
answer them  As many of your questions
as we have time
to see, let's start with our first
question, Doctor Bonilla, you talked a
lot about genotification in the
HPV spin, but in a summary,
could you talk to us in a general way?
What is the importance of including
notification in screening and how
broad must be must include those
low risk genotypes
that is an extremely interesting question
one cannot be explained today 2021
Why There are still tests on the
market that are not for research
that include low risk genotypes
because the asscp in 2016 is very clear
that is to say that doctors must
defend that these tests are not
in the  market What happens my intention is
that patients do not have
cervical cancer, that is what screening is for
detecting within the healthy
population screenings healthy population Which are the
women at risk of having cancer and
those patients who have
low-risk HPV where it has been  demonstrated that
they will not generate cancer Or at least the
probability is extremely minimal these
patients should not be taken to
body copies to biopsies on
treatments in case they are positive
for these low-risk HPV groups it
is for this reason that the tests
should not  report low risk, so
they will generate anxiety and over-
treatment only high-risk viruses
14 genotypes They should be
available in
screening tests within prevention programs
Thank you very much
One last question due to a matter of
time, is there an indication for screening tests  HPV
for contracting control
does not include it in the talk but it is a
highly important topic  before and this
allows us to summarize the three indications
of HPV tests as screening as
triage or second test in ascos and as
control in the post-treatment follow-up
all women who have
undergone conservative surgery such
as conization or
cauterization  for the management of
precancerous or pre-neoclassical lesions, you should
have an HPV test every year During
the first three years, if this
HPV test is negative, the probability that
the woman will relapse into the disease is
zero;
if this test is positive, the patient
can repeat it  the disease and needs or
requires more frequent controls, it
is essential to use
HPV tests to
carry out this follow-up and to be able to identify those
patients who are going to relapse into the
disease.
Good doctor Bonilla. Thank you very much
again for your time today and your
interesting  presentation i
would also like to thank la cruz and
our sponsor cien affairs
water ntificates for subscribing
to today's educational webcast before we go I
'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their questions the
questions we didn't have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be answered
through information from  contact information you
provide at registration
this webcam can be viewed on demand
until July 2022
you will be notified by
email when it is available
for playback we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues
who may have missed
today's event  So it will be until next time,
thank you very much and see you later